it's out as hell i really wish i got
some twinkies so now it's gonna take
super long for them to dry
and i can't do this without those i
really want to finish this
what's up guys i'm q and today i'm gonna
be everesting with zero practice
so everything is this crazy physical
fitness challenge where you choose one
hill
and you either run bike or virtually run
or bike the height of mount everest
i'm decently fit so i feel like i might
have a chance to do this so i'm going to
give you guys a quick walkthrough of my
setup
because i got a lot going on here all
right so this is the kicker climb
it's an indoor grade simulator and it's
pretty much connected by bluetooth to
the game and it's going to allow my bike
to have the same gradient happening in
the game
this bike is from canyon you can
actually take the wheels on or off and
connect it
for indoor riding or for outdoor riding
and lastly is a kicker smart trainer and
that's going to be able to track how
hard i'm actually pushing
to get to this everest attempt all right
so i chose to do virtual everything
inside of the zwift half the hill i
chose is called epic ko and ford they
have to do this hill 22 times
to successfully complete my evers
attempt i just realized that i forgot to
change my avatar so
i'm like a 30 year old white guy i'm
about 47 minutes in
about 1035 feet so
just got 28 000 more to go how hard
could it be
so i just finished my first hill uh
right now i'm on my first ascent so my
guy's just going by himself
doing this thing i'm gonna grab a quick
bite to eat right now just refuel and
get right back into it so hopefully i
can definitely do this
all right about two thousand feet in
been riding for about an hour and thirty
minutes including this turtle
yeah starting to realize i'm gonna be
here for a while
oh there we go and i was five minutes
faster
surprisingly so what happened here is
that i finished hill number two and i
did not know how to do a u-turn
so i ended up going down to descent for
epic k-1 ford instead of
turning back around but to get back to
where i had to go i had to go up epic
kale and reverse
which had an average gradient that was
way higher than the ford
i don't know what to do yeah early
mistake i will not make that again
i'm gonna have some my friend joining me
from the cyrus team just some people to
talk to
someone so lonely on this how are you
feeling
you're a few hours in so i feel good
this is my first time going this far
for this long kind of happy i wanted
this reverse because i'm showing me like
okay i got this like you know once we
get to like
eight nine ten hours just like do you
want to finish it or do you not want to
finish it
right now i'm saying yeah but who knows
how to get there
it'll be mind over matter especially at
some point
where it's not so much about fitness
it's about
how how determined are you you'll have
bad moments and you'll have good moments
if you're in a tough spot in one of the
climbs just
get some food down and the next time up
will be better you guys think i got a
chance
i think you got it you sound like your
head in the right space
which is is everything yeah that's like
that's a battle right
you're quitting you're kind of crazy i'm
gonna be honest
yeah cyrus team shout out to those guys
man
i noticed during this first session that
my neck started to hurt so it's
definitely something i gotta like watch
for going forward eating my food very
quick
drink a little bit of gatorade you know
and just try to refuel a little bit
i didn't take a shower yet but you know
whatever
i like washed off a little bit a little
bit refreshed
riding with the cyrus team was was dope
uh
they were great they were very
encouraging um they gave me some good
tips
definitely got to make sure i'm eating
enough staying hydrated but i'm ready to
go so i'm gonna eat
get back to it
[Music]
yo it's getting real i'm feeling my
first cramp coming right now
i didn't think it was gonna come out
early but i'm cramping
right here oh okay i gotta grab a banana
right now
there's a clearly in that car here
another thing gotta turn this uh
fan back on i think i'm doing a pretty
good job staying fueled and hydrated
all right final stretch left eight
good i really wish i got some twinkies
like
that is really one of my favorite snacks
i heard they're vegan too oh nice oreos
all right so i'm on my break right now i
have been a shower real quick
i got a bolognese veggie pasta and also
got
this heating pad on my butt because it
hurts really bad
i tried to wash my like bottom things
but my washer stopped like halfway
and just was filled with water so now
it's going to take super long for them
to dry
and i can't do this without those
so we'll see what happens but
i'm still trying to finish
whoa
definitely a little bit more difficult
to eat
i'm looking at where i'm at how much
further i got to go
like he's super late this bike is hella
loud
pretend a quick quick break
i'm not gonna get a bike though
we got time for that
[Music]
it's like 5 a.m right now you know
man i'm just like i really don't think i
can go anymore
just can't do it like i really want to
keep going
part of me just feel i can like i can do
this like but
i don't know what it is but i just do
not have the energy
but let me just like let's just sit for
a second drink some water drink some
gatorade just try to like get myself
together but
if i can't feel it in like 30 45 minutes
it's called quiz
i've never been this worn out before in
my entire life can't lie
i definitely feel pretty defeated i feel
like i i put my best effort towards it
and um honestly i think if those pants
did get stuck in the washing machine
i honestly feel like i would have gotten
closer it kind of sucks
but yeah i'm just eat this food and
hopefully
i'll feel better later impossible
breakfast sandwich
that might cheer me up quentin
wake up just wanted to let you know how
proud i
am of you that was an amazing
ride for a first attempt i can't believe
that you did that
um but then again i can you do all
things well
and you'll continue to do things well
what's this i'm hearing about your
washing machine blew up i can't take
this
hey quentin uh congrats on the ride man
uh
that was a really incredible attempt
virtual eversting eversting in general
is no joke i remember riding with you
at night getting up in the morning the
next day
and seeing that you were still on there
and still going
but i just wanted to give you a shout
out uh some kudos
nice nice work man right on so i guess
things aren't that bad after all
like um we didn't finish it but
everybody
still got my back yes it's fun this is a
good experience and i'm just so happy i
did it
and hopefully i can try it again because
i really think i can get this done
so we'll see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you